-These are our favorite
#DescribeAMovieBadly responses
from you guys.
First one's from @10butterflies.
She says, "'The Shining' -
a family has
a bad Airbnb experience."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Weird twins in the hallway,
etc."
-Smelled like oranges.
-This one's from
@justicefordack.
They say, "'The Hunger Games' --
girl ruins her sister's chance
to be on TV."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Selfish.
This one's from @squirrelthepam.
-Squirrel the Pam?
Pam the cooking spray?
-Maybe Pam the squirrel.
She says,
"'Lord of the Rings' --
a group spends nine hours
returning jewelry."
[ Laughter ]
-My refund.
-Got it at Jared.
-This one's from my pal
Horatio Sanz.
He said, "'Star Wars' --
daddy issues in space."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I am your father."
"No, you're not.
You'll never be."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @jswilliams1962.
He says, "'The Wizard of Oz' -
women try to kill each other
over a pair of shoes."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from Keisuke Hoashi
He says, "'Fever Pitch' --
a man chooses to love
25 huge, sweaty men
over Drew Barrymore."
Hey!
♪♪♪♪
That was mean.
♪♪ -True that ♪♪
This one's from @mauledbysmokey.
-Ooh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-She probably thought
he was giving her,
like, fire safety tips.
-Yeah, exactly. He was not
He was mauled.
-He's an animal. He's a bear
-Yeah, he's a bear.
-Sure, he's wearing human pant
and a hat.
-But he's still an animal.
Mauled a man to death.
-No, it's a woman.
-Oh, a woman.
-And she's still alive.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @mauledbysmokey.
She Says,
"'2001: A Space Odyssey' -
man trips balls while
waiting for I.T. support."
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @zachmyles.
He says,
"'The Breakfast Club' --
they do not eat breakfast.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Spoiler alert.
-Spoiler.
There's no breakfast.
-They don't even eat breakfast
[ Laughter ]
Calm down, dude.
It's just a movie.
This one's from @sethpanatoni.
-Oh.
-11.
-I wasn't done.
Yeah, there's 10 others.
-There's 10 other
Seth Panatonis.
-That's right.
This is @sethpanatoni11.
He says, "'Indiana Jones' --
the Nazis threaten
world domination,
so the U.S.
sends one man with a whip.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from
@ryanbartholomee.
Oh, he says, "'Aquaman" --
bath time but bigger."
[ Laughter ]
Last one's from @alliedoc.
She says, "'Titanic' --
an old lady talks about that
time she got laid on a cruise.
There you go. Those are
our "Tonight Show" hashtags.